[Music]
today we have to cancel the washington
post for an article published yesterday
with the exceedingly bizarre headline
zookeeping isn't common in the black
community
this black zookeeper wants to change
that now if you have a moderately
well-tuned bs detector
you hopefully have already noticed a
major problem with the claim being made
here
yes zookeeping isn't common in the black
community it also isn't common in any
other community zookeeping is among is
common among zookeepers and that's it
from what i've read statistically over
90 percent of zookeepers engage in
zookeeping but the numbers are
considerably lower for all other
communities including white people i've
been a white person most of my life and
i've never known a zookeeper it's not
like zookeeping is a profession that
white suburban parents tend to push
their kids into
growing up i never had a friend tell me
man you know i really want to be go to
school and be a doctor but my dad is
pressuring me to keep zoos
he won't shut up about it
you know he says if i was a zookeeper my
father was a zookeeper
son you come from a long line of
zookeepers
now that's not a conversation i ever had
but let's not let any of that get in the
way of racializing the zookeeping
profession so here's the washington post
craig saffo was at fresno chaffee zoo's
big cats exhibit when he saw the man
outbounds this black guy in a zoo
uniform sappho said he had this walk
like the coolest walk you'll ever see
and i think ah that's cool they let
their volunteers come in
then he realized the man wasn't a
volunteer he had his training buoy his
target stick his meat pouch sappho said
and he realized
oh my god he's the keeper
now just interject here
you should not be walking around the zoo
with your target sticker meat patch meat
pouch out um
you should there are children present
but that's neither here nor there back
to the article it says the man didn't
fit the profile of who most zookeepers
in america are white and female
i was mortified that i said that sappho
said because like the man in fresno
california he was watching during a
conference in 2018
and sappho 2 is a black zookeeper
zapho47 is the curator of large
carnivores at the smithsonian's national
zoo in dc and for decades he has often
been one of the few if not the only
zookeeper of color in the room even as
his responsibility and prestige in the
field grew his black friends would
dismiss his work as white people stuff
and indeed the field is about 74 white
now he's like 74 white
but white people also comprise about the
same percentage of the overall
population in the country that would
mean that white people are
proportionally represented among
zookeepers what's the problem here
and even if zookeepers were 100 white
even if there were no zocs zookeepers of
color still what's the problem here
we'll have to read on to find out
it says when he was at work at the
national zoo where he's been for more
than 25 years
people who didn't know him often assumed
as safo did with the black zookeeper at
fresno that he's a volunteer or even a
janitor the same thing happened to
jordan weasley an animal zookeeper at
cougar mountain zoo in washington state
who said that he gets asked if i'm if
i'm a janitor if i clean the bathrooms
when he's walking around the zoo
now another brief side note
um
that doesn't happen i mean i don't mean
to question jordan weasley's lived
experience but i don't think that
happens nobody's walking up to a random
black guy at the zoo and saying excuse
me do you clean the bathrooms
that's the kind of thing that you think
white people would do if you've never
met one in person and have learned about
them only through ibramex candy seminars
no white person is just going to go up
to a black guy and say you there yes the
toilets are unsightly in the restrooms
please attend to them at once i assume
you're the janitor after all
i'm just i'm skeptical about that but
let's keep reading a little more it says
veesley32 whose social media posts as
jungle jordan are wildly popular finally
tackled his um
his unicorn status in an emotional viral
video
okay we have to stop again because you
know i had to go find that emotional
viral video about black zoo keeping and
i did find it and this viral video by
the way was filmed in 2018 and has 4 000
views on youtube so we're really
stretching the bounds of the viral
designation here unless the guy unless
they meant to the guy film the video
while sick with a virus i'm not sure but
anyway here it is
[Music]
what is up everybody it's your boy
jungle jordan as you can see by the
title of this video this is a really
important video that i've been wanting
to make for a long time and it's a
pretty emotional topic for me and that
but i feel like this needs to be said
and everything i'm about to say means a
lot to me and it's real close to my
heart it's really hard to talk about so
like i said taking a long time to even
try to attempt to make this video even
as i'm filming right now it took me a
long time to try to think of an intro of
how to start this video so i'm going to
just get off and get into it i'm going
to start by saying i
am a black zookeeper now this means a
lot there's a lot that comes with this
with this phrase there's two words there
black
zookeeper both probably words you would
have never heard combined together
matter of fact never probably have seen
those words combined together but yes we
do exist
well yeah i mean those aren't words i
hear together very often because i
rarely talk about zookeepers no offense
i don't hear any words combined with the
word zookeeper because this subject
simply doesn't
come up very often in my life and on the
rare occasion that i have had the
opportunity to discuss zookeeping in any
depth i would normally refer to the
zookeepers as just zookeepers without
feeling the need to fix any racial
designation to them
i mean now that you mention it i did see
an asian zookeeper at a zoo a few weeks
ago but i didn't go up to them and say
excuse me asian zookeeper i have a
question
in fact i didn't think of them as an
asian zookeeper at all really i think i
just thought of them as a zookeeper who
happened to be asian
but all that is beside the point
i go back to the question i posed at the
beginning
even if black people are
underrepresented amongst zookeepers why
is that automatically a problem
why does it matter
see this is what the racialists do they
walk around the country randomly poking
their heads into rooms and saying hey
there should be more black people in
here
that doesn't they don't seem to care
much about the math
there are a finite number of black
people in the country in the world even
there's only so many to go around and
yet and yet they demand dramatically
increased numbers of black people and
other racial minorities in every in
every field and in every walk of life
and in every nook and cranny of society
but then the math doesn't work
if you insist on more black zookeepers
and your demands are fulfilled
that's going to mean fewer black people
in whatever field or profession they
would have gone into instead
that problem should be apparent i would
think
also nobody's talking taking into
account free choice
each individual black person in the
country
is a human being with free will
if not many of them become zookeepers
it's because not many have decided to
make that choice with their lives
you can create more black zookeepers
only by convincing black individuals
to not choose whatever they were going
to choose and choose zookeeping instead
but in what way does that represent
progress that's a lateral move that's a
reshuffling
you're shifting pieces around on the
board you're not adding new ones
or perhaps i'm looking at this the wrong
way
if we can't increase black
representation in zookeeping by
increasing the volume of black
zookeepers the other option is to
decrease the volume of white zookeepers
maybe we should fire 95 percent of the
white zookeepers across the country
thereby tripling the percentage of black
zookeepers in one fell swoop better yet
the most equal thing would be to have no
zookeepers at all
open the cages let the animals wander
around
as they will
that would be true equity
it would also make for a much more
entertaining zoo experience
and most importantly racial balance at
the zoo will finally be the last piece
we need in order to usher in racial
harmony across the globe
seems like a crazy plan perhaps
but it's better than the one offered by
the washington post and black zookeeper
craig sappho
and that's why they are both today i i'm
afraid to say
cancelled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends